la rougeole est une maladie vous savez
virale contagieuse elle est en forte
recrudescence un peu partout dans le
monde
cette année on met sur le vaccin pour
l'attaqué on pourrait dire d'autant plus
qu'un nouvelle étude américaine qui
révèle que le virus de la rougeole peut
avoir des conséquences importantes sur
notre système u minh humanitaire on en
parle avec le docteur karl weiss il est
expert des maladies infectieuses à
l'hôpital général juif de montréal
bonjour bonjour expliquez-nous un peu en
quoi le fait d'avoir la rougeole en
effet sur notre système immunitaire ce
que j'ai compris c'est que ça effacerait
la mémoire de notre système immunitaire
c'est ça c'est à dire que le virus est à
créer vos globules blancs qui sont un
petit peu la mémoire de votre système
immunitaire est donc en les attaquant et
en les détruisant les gardiens de votre
mémoire immunitaire serait effacée et
donc ce que vous avez appris auparavant
défendant qu'ont certains microbes
serait en partie éliminé et
disparaîtrait de votre capacité à vous
défendre
et comme si vous voulez vous avant si on
faisait un parallèle avec une guerre
c'est comme si on détruisait des soldats
aguerris qui ont été déjà reconduit et
donc qui serait éliminé
et lorsque vous allez attaquer à nouveau
par quelque chose d'autre et bien vous
allez être démuni de soldats aguerris et
éprouvée aux combattants donc la
rougeole fait ça c'est ce que révélait
cette étude américaine qui a été publiée
dans sa haine ce qui est une revue
extrêmement sérieuse et qui montre que
bon même si on survit à la rougeole et
la majorité des gens s'en vont survivre
mais il reste quand même avec des
séquelles que même si vous avez fait la
rougeole
vous avez guéri qu'ils aient un impact
sur votre système immunitaire
oui la rougeole au québec jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'avènement du vaccin à la fin
des années 60 c'est extrêmement commun
et à peu près tous les québécois faisait
la rougeole et en survivez mais il ya
aussi des gens qui ont mûri qui reste
avec des séquelles
il y avait des gens qui restait avec des
séquelles neurologiques importantes
aimer aimer les gens évidemment un
moment donné elle est peut-être
récupérer avec leur haut niveau de leurs
amis militaires il n'empêche que il
semble avoir un impact important par
rapport aux gens qui sont vaccinées
versus ne le sont pas et donc
vaccin ne protège pas jusqu'au plat
rougeole il protège contre les effets
négatifs du virus de la rougeole à long
terme sur votre système immunitaire
donc ce que j'en comprends c'est que oui
on pourrait sauver de la rougeole mais
dont on rattrape et d'autres maladies
on a peut-être eu des vaccins mais il
serait plus efficace dont parce que
notre système
la perte de cette mémoire là et mourir
de d'autres maladies par exemple cette
amnésie immunitaire là
ap a été détectée donc chez les enfants
qui avaient été vaccinés contre la
rougeole est tout à fait donc et souvent
on voit ça avec les vaccins vous savez
les vaccins même s'ils sont pas 100%
efficace tout le temps même s'ils sont
très bons et parfois efficace à 99 %
pour les gens qui vont qui ont été
vaccinés qui vont faire la maladie ont
souvent faire une maladie qui et je
dirai beaucoup moins sévère avec
beaucoup moins de complications que les
autres ça c'est la première chose puis
la deuxième chose c'est que l'impact à
long terme de faire la maladie n'est
probablement pas aussi négatif que chez
les gens qui sont la maladie mais qui
n'ont jamais été vacciné auparavant
détenu est ce que le système immunitaire
peut recouvrer la mémoire
oui tout à fait alors quand vous êtes en
bonne santé votre système immunitaire va
réapprendre donc il va réapprendre
il va se reconstruire il va il va
essayer de faire encore une fois je vous
dirais des anticorps il va essayer de
rebâtir sa structure mais ça va prendre
un temps d'apprentissage c'est quand
finalement si vous savez vous avez
appris quelque chose et on vous disait
maintenant on va effacer votre capacité
de savoir lire il faut réapprendre à
dire alors c'est possible c'est faisable
mais il faut que vous reparti de zéro
alors que vous aviez déjà une base
auparavant comme si on enlevait dans une
protection qu'on a construit pendant des
années en terminant justement vous
parlez de d'efficacité de vaccins on est
en pleine campagne de vaccination ça
commence en fait contre la grippe
saisonnière
la question qu'on se pose chaque année 1
c est ce que le vaccin cette année sera
efficace ben on l'espère c'est difficile
de répondre
vous savez les vaccins sont des vaccins
pour la grippe l'efficacité est très
variable d'une année à l'autre
le vaccin contre la grippe c'est encore
une fois un vaccin extraordinaire mais
c'est un vaccin qui va protéger des
complications pour les populations à
risque c'est à dire que si on veut
maximiser l'impact de cette vaccination
c'est de vacciner des gens qui sont qui
ont des maladies sous jacentes des
problèmes cardiaques pulmonaires et noro
et cetera
et ces gens là pour ne pas avoir de
complications sévères de la grippe et en
mourir
le vaccin peut être utile pour les
autres c'est sûr c'est un vaccin dont
l'efficacité est relative c'est pas une
très bonne efficacité et qui est très
variable d'une année à l'autre alors est
ce qui va être efficace cette année on
va savoir une fois que la
saison va vraiment commencer et qu'on va
voir comment les gens qui ont été
vaccinés vont se comporter et au passage
on a déjà des cas de grippe au québec
pas beaucoup mais on en a encore à
environ je vous dirais 25 à 30 toutes
les semaines déclaré alors espérons que
la saison de la grippe ne sera pas trop
sérieux je pense que quand même quoi 4,4
virus de la grippe la dent dans notre
vaccin cette année alors on va essayer
de couvrir large
tout ça c'est un vaccin quadrivalent
londres savait l'influenza il ya une
influence a à b et c
donc dans ce vaccin là il ya deux
souches qu'on appelle à et de souche
qu'on appelle b donc c'est un vaccin
cadre une balle et qui protège contre
les deux souches principal de la grippe
qui ne causent des problèmes les sous
qu'on appelle h1n1 et la souche qu'on
appelle h3n2 est jongleur
oui mais ça va il s'est tout à coup en
espérant donc les sera efficace vaccin
merci beaucoup de plaisir